وقع وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه اليوم مع
نائب رئيس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه القطريه
الشيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن الثاني اعلان
خطاب نيه بشان التعاون الثنائي في القضايا
المتعلقه باستضافه كاس العالم وذلك على
اهمش الحوار الاستراتيجيه الخامس بين
الولايات المتحده وقطر وسيمكن هذا الاعلان
البلدين من تبادل المعارف بشان الاستعداد
الاستضافه بطوله كاس العالم كما سيعل
جانبان الى البناء على التقدم الذي تم
احرازه في كاس العالم 2002
لتعزيز امكانيه الوصول بشكل اكبر للمشجعين
ذوي الاحتياجات الخاصه لحضور المباريات
هذا واستعرض امير دوله قطر الشيخ تميم بن
حمد الثاني مع وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
يطالب لينكن العلاقات الاستراتيجيه بين
البلدين واوجهها تعزيزها في مختلف
المجالات لذلك حسب ما جاء في تغريده
للديوان الاميري القطريه الذي اوضح ان
اللقاء عقد في استاد احمد بن علي في
العاصمه القطريه الدوحه